the argument I would I would use around
windfall taxes is okay other people have
implemented them we are seeing real
consequences they are always a bad idea
um we we have major energy companies
that are now
um get firing hundreds of people we're
seeing um them take their money to other
countries we're seeing hundreds of
millions of pounds leaving this country
when it could be invested in cleaner and
Greener energy here the real
consequences to all of this and I I
think Richard C Nick knows this I think
he's possibly one of the most
economically literate Prime Ministers
we've ever had and uh you know I think
he's well aware of these arguments he
can see the consequences he's in charge
now he can change the direction